en directo a vamos a Ciudad de México
allí el presidente de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador recibió el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken
y a la secretaria de comercio Gina
Raimundo el mandatario afirmó que fue
una reunión productiva y amistosa y
además de ella podría salir un acuerdo
de comercio entre los dos países
conectamos entonces con nuestro
corresponsal en México Mario carbonell
Mario buenas noches para usted y
cuéntenos qué pasó hoy en la
conversación entre México y Estados
Unidos Cuál fue el principal acuerdo
Hola Pues en efecto se llevó a cabo esta
segunda edición del diálogo económico de
alto nivel en el que pues algunas
expectativas estaban centradas en el
tema de las consultas del temec por el
tema eléctrico sin embargo Bueno tanto
la parte mexicana como la estadounidense
dejaron en claro que esto quedará en el
mecanismo que para tal efecto fue creado
en el marco del temec qué tal modo que
el tema importante en este diálogo fue
la invitación que hizo el Gobierno de
Joe biden a México para que se sume en
este gran esfuerzo para la producción de
semiconductores tanto Gina raimondo como
Anthony blinken dijeron que desean que
México se sume a esta a esta producción
de que se enmarca desde luego en la ley
de chips que fue
sentenciada en Estados Unidos y que
implica una inversión de alrededor de 50
mil millones de dólares esto dijeron
Pues
pone todo en la mesa para que México y
Estados Unidos sean líderes en la
producción de vehículos eléctricos pero
que lo hagan dijo blinken de manera
conjunta que trabajen de la mano para
fabricar estos vehículos y toda la
cadena de suministro que tiene que ver
con los semiconductores y de esta manera
también cumplir con los compromisos
climáticos se abordaron también otros
temas como cooperación para el
desarrollo y atacar ahí la causa de la
migración en Centroamérica Mario y le
preguntó Cómo recibió México esa
invitación de la Casa Blanca
bueno el canciller Marcelo ebrard dijo
que es una oportunidad histórica que es
de esas oportunidades que se dan una vez
en la vida y por lo mismo México acepta
con mucho entusiasmo y gratitud por qué
porque esto va a implicar la generación
de miles de empleos y Esto va también a
generar que la economía de México crezca
probablemente al doble de lo que está
creciendo actualmente con esta
invitación a participar en la
elaboración de semiconductores que hay
que decirlo no nada más es en la
producción sino también en la parte de
ensamblaje de pruebas técnicas de
empaquetamiento dijo ebrard que también
Esto va a
contribuir a que se reduzca de manera
más pronta la pobreza en la secretaria
de economía Tatiana clouthier también
señaló que México Tiene un plan el plan
Sonora para explotar el litio y que el
presidente López Obrador lo compartió
con los funcionarios estadounidenses y
que tiene también que ver con
precisamente toda Magdalena de
suministro desde la extracción de litio
hasta la elaboración de semiconductores
de manera tal que bueno este fue el
acuerdo principal en materia económica
también se perfiló el próximo encuentro
en materia de seguridad para el mes de
octubre y se habló también del encuentro
de líderes de América del Norte A
celebrarse en diciembre